l'argument écologique d'hubert ne tient
pas la route selon une étude
californienne
les autorités responsables de la qualité
de l'air ont découvert qu'un déplacement
avec hubert ou un autre service
d'autopartage génère 70 % plus de gaz à
effet de serre que s'ils lisent
d'utilisateurs avaient choisi de faire
ce même déplacement avec leur propre
voiture
la raison est simple entre deux courses
et chauffeurs doivent parcourir de
grandes distances pour rejoindre leurs
proches un client en fait 40% des
kilomètres parcourus par les chauffeurs
d'hubert se font sans passagers des élus
californiens tentent donc de resserrer
la réglementation notamment pour faire
augmenter le pourcentage de véhicules
électriques dans ces flottes auto
partage les déplacements en voiture
général du quart des émissions
polluantes de la californie
[Musique]